l'école est à buenos aires à merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france vous avez
donc été le chef du gouvernement italien
entre le 28 avril 2013 et le 22 février
vous étiez au sein d'une coalition menée
par le le parti démocrate de matteo
renzi qu'est ce que vous pensez du pari
de giuseppe côté partir pour mieux
revenir alors qu'il est poussé par
matteo renzi je pense que c'était le
seul choix c'est le seul choix qui
devait la postière et la possible de
faire mais je pense que c'est une crise
grave incompréhensible dans un moment
dramatique comme le moment qu'on est en
train de vivre dans tous nos pays
européens avec la crise sanitaire
franchement que pays soit bloqué dans
une crise de toute politique ça fait
désormais déjà une dizaine de jours le
pays dans une crise politique et ça va
continuer pour des jours et des jours et
ça va rendre les autorités de l'état et
des régions même moi capable je pense de
contrer les problèmes de la pandémie
parce que les gens sont occupés
aujourd'hui s'est disputée sur la
politique franchement je trouve ça
irresponsable et la cause est surtout
dans la personne de matt et rennes si
l'ancien prises et président du conseil
italien qui aujourd'hui à la tête d'un
petit parti est en train de bloquer tout
je pense pour des raisons de politique
personnelle et franchement je ne vois
pas où ça peut aller sinon dans une
aggravation de la situation politique
politicienne donc à à vous entendre qui
a la meilleure place pour s'allier à
l'ancien premier ministre alors qu'il a
déclaré le cherche une coalition il est
en train de parler avec les députés à
laquelle sénateurs il est en train de
parler avec les forces politiques ce
n'est pas simple parce que la droite et
la droite souverainiste italienne anti
européennes sortent les fortes au
parlement les sortes dans le pays elle
veut des élections
donc il y a aussi un petit risque
je pense plus que petit
que le blocage politique et l'absence
d'une solution amène peut-être à des
élections le plus tôt que possible et je
pense que ce serait un problème
gravissime pour un pays qui ne peut pas
se permettre
franchement des mois de blocage mois de
campagne électorale
on a à contrer une pandémie avec les
problèmes en plus de récession
économique qui sont super grave donc
franchement incompréhensible que cette
politique politicienne bloque tout
maintenant vous m'avez devancé sur cette
question qui venait justement au sujet
des élections législatives la coalition
si coalition il ya si giuseppe quand
elle arriva à la voir est-ce qu'elle
serait solide ou fragiles et du coup
quid de futures élections législatives
prochainement c'est donc une réalité
selon vous je pense que le parlement va
faire le possible pour éviter une
élection anticipée et le président de la
république
de même en plus comme vous savez il ya
eu un référendum ali qui a coupé est
rendu le parlement plus petit donc une
grande partie des actuels parlementaire
ne vont pas revenir ce qui est toujours
une grande poussée à ne pas anticiper
les élections naturellement et le
président de la république aussi veut
éviter ça mais le blocage est là
derrière le coin donc je pense que ce
n'est pas une hypothèse impossible si la
crise continue pour des jours et des
jours sans solution comment on peut
expliquer cette instabilité politique
chronique en italie
plus de 70 71 gouvernement si je ne
m'abuse depuis 1946 la chose est liée au
système qui est d'un système
parlementaire pur un système dans lequel
donc le parlement et le centre du tout
et dans notre système italien la
représentativité est la première
priorité de la loi électorale plus que
l'efficacité de l'action du gouvernement
c'est un système doc qui a des avantages
d'un système qui dans la possibilité de
faire en sorte que tout
forces politiques soient représentés et
donc tous soient associés au moins à la
vie institutionnelle il aime énorme
différence avec la france qui a un
système qui préfèrent la gouvernabilité
au lieu de la représentativité en france
il ya deux forces politiques très fortes
qui sont très peu présentes ou absente
du parlement et ce n'est pas le cas chez
nous et des évidemment tout ça a créé
des problèmes de gouvernance
on a cherché le changer les choses avec
un référendum il y a quatre ans qui n'a
pas eu un effet de positif et l'as la
loi électorale n'aide pas non plus la
fragmentation de force politique
là aussi les deux pas et je pense aussi
que la crise est liée au moment
particulièrement difficile que le pays
est en train de vivre avec la pandémie
avec la récession économique tant que je
trouve que ce soit un moment vraiment
très grave très difficile dans la vie de
mon pays dernière question rapidement à
enrico letta si vous final il devait y
avoir des élections législatives
prochainement
quelle partie
en tirerait bénéfices ce qui a un parti
qui est plus en avant que l'autre on
sait qui est le mouvement ching quest ix
les cinq étoiles de deux j'ai oublié son
nom de 10 miles ya également la lega
nord de la ligue du nord de l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur qui pourrait
et bien tiré son épingle du jeu il est
évident qu'aujourd'hui il y a les deux
leaders de la droite souverainiste qui
ont reçu un cadeau
le cadeau vienne de rennes qui a fait
tomber le gouvernement et donc donne aux
à la droite souverainiste une chance
qu'elle n'imaginait pas avoir le matin
sévigné et donc salvini et meloni qui
sont les deux leaders de la droite
souverainiste
il est évident que s'il y avait une
élection mais je répète ce n'est pas
encore le cas ce serait une élection
entre deux noms le centre gauche et les
5 étoiles
d'un côté et la droite souverainiste de
l'autre et les petits partis de centre
qui devrait choisir de quel côté se
mettre et à la fin les italiens auraient
à choisir et ce serait je pense une
élection très très serré merci enrico
letta d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes un ancien
président du conseil italien autrement
dit un ancien premier ministre italien
et puis vous êtes également le président
de l'institut jacques delors